gracq bio tard le serveur à des knicks
est pas ça nous aidera guillotin
aujourd'hui je me fais passer pour un
serveur amnésique dans le piège qui va
suivre il a une complice qui s'appelle
andré et la piéger c'est sa maman
sandrine sais pas si longtemps pour aux
états unis marie va bien sans vous
l'avez vraiment mais non non je connais
pas d'accord alors je confonds peu
d'athlètes je vous amène les quartiers
est-ce que vous avez un petit café avec
les desserts ou comment ce à quoi vous
êtes si nombreux décors et par d'autres
pour vous mais demandez l'addition si
vous les cafés en fait je pensais pas à
vous et je vous appris votre votre
commande
au nom des tartares et anin martin
d'accord quoi blanco veut mais on sait
quand on a cassé noté
j'ai perdu je sais plus je retrouve mon
carnet c'était deux calamars avait dit
de calamars lucas la marne
ok ok avec moi donc il est odieux mais
le catch up
enfin me vendre
[Musique]
je vous encaissez voulait repartir sur
la place aux quelque chose et cause pour
les pl un dépôt
[Musique]
merci
la fois content d'être là
on vous parlait je compare les deux
secondes certaines vont travailler tout
aussi
[Musique]
mais vous présentiez ses pointes au jeu
sans fumée noire il n'y a pas que
l'anniversaire vous déplacez pas
beaucoup il n'y a pas de ghetto comme on
[Musique]
dit
dms s'est pas s'il va parvenir à passer
a commenté
[Musique]
regardez
est ce que sont les 3 bet
[Musique]
vt
[Applaudissements]
fait partir le gâteau d'anniversaire
qu'on cuisine
donc ce sera livré pour la fin du repas
je me suis renseigné
c'est à 3,55 euros kg sur la carte il
est parti en cuisine obligatoire ça vous
voyez ça répond c'est bien parce que ça
commence à bien faire si ça continue
j'ai même partir sans payer votre ami
m'a surpris ce point commun 4faire
commun c'est ce qu'on peut mettre les
choses à plat
non je n'ai pas les choses à plat avec
vous ça suffit monsieur m'a demandé un
jour d'anniversaire pour vous pour vous
faire un cadeau
ce n'est pas mon anniversaire ma part je
suis né au mois de mars que six mois de
mars puis le mois de septembre est allé
droit depuis le départ il n'y a pas
d'anniversaire nous entende et la [ __ ]
merde mais nous qui commence à déraper
le gâteau d'anniversaire à 55,2 expliqué
hier si je commande des choses que vous
m'avez demandé et et qu'ensuite
mais plus il y ait des matières
premières parce qu'on commande on n'a
pas ça par la vue qui demande à l'état
verse r c'est vous qui l'avez inventé
les goûters d'anniversaire ci a pas
d'anniversaire de mexique on va le
prendre a remporté je vais vous faire un
aveu roi
c'est une manière vache par le
ferez-vous je vais voir la voilà pour
les verrous faire presque on est
vraiment désolé et par rapport à leur
président ne cache pas grave crise et
non la porcherie président vous mais
demandez par rapport aux maraîchers si
le mari chier pour un fraisier on a
réellement vu rien bouleversé d'arracher
pour vqprd fried on armes allemandes et
là on a fini tu vois pour l'oscar du
rassemblement des contrats excusez moi
non mais arrêtez c'est mon petit à ses
partenaires aux maraîchers on n'a rien
demandé
[Musique]
certes je vais la raison
mais maintenant j'en ai ras-le-bol ses
portes demain ça pue c'est un homme qui
va commander
alors un seul à tapas quatre ont dû vous
savez quoi la soirée que j'ai passé à
stop on accorde au gâteau vous allez y
brancher un mois 55 croire je compte sur
nous alors pour votre information je
passais le packaging
vous avez deux de nice mais bien sûr
dans l'écouté de magalou quoi un froid
va mieux en rire vous de présenter ça
fait deux heures chez là je veux bien
rire j'ai bien rigolé au début mais n'a
au bout de deux ans et demi
franchement rapide catherine et côté moi
non c'est pas catherine d'accord avec
vous arrêtez veux pas terminer sa
quatrième je n'avais pas catherine
j'habite juste à côté juste à côté
si jamais vous verrez magali si c'est
clair qu'à trêve à l'arrêt je la préfère
catherine servan pape aurait renoncé
même pas tant c'est inadmissible par et
télécoms rien mais je vais faire un
scandale vous arrêter terminez votre
habitat je n'avais pas quatrième
anniversaire parce que je peux vous dire
un petit train c'est là bas rien vous
attendez plus de venir et écoutez moi
s'il vous plaît tout ça c'était une
caméra cachée
[Applaudissements]
l'otan va
chez grégory grégori hergault